it was the game that coined a dozen
catchphrases
and made over a billion dollars in
quarters
but nba jam almost never saw the light
of day
oh
this is nba jam game designer mark
termell so we put together a demo a
videotape vhs we sent it to the nba and
said hey we're making this cool game and
they immediately shut it down and said
no we don't want the nba logo in the
arcades so once we got rejected
we made a video tape of nice family
entertainment centers and we sent that
back to them and said look you know this
your logo can be here so they relented
and uh provided the license
when we put it in the arcade for the
very first time there were no stats that
differentiated the players everybody
assumed that shaq was a bad three-point
shooter or stockton could steal the ball
so we realized pretty quickly that we
had to you know up our game
to match the real world
well if it's just looking at pure
attributes i happen to be the best
player in the game
when you actually put in my secret
character it just shows question marks
for the stats but they're all tens or
nines
got it i'm pretty good at nba
to test the claim we had mark hack into
the machine there we go and turn on
cheat codes
all right now we're talking
usually when somebody finds out that
i've made nba jam they say i spent so
much money on that nba jam or you know i
flunked a class in college because of
nba jam
well i look at the game now i wish it
were smoother but it was the technology
at the time
the game still holds up today
you